foreign
[Music]
we've been flying over his estate for
the past two hours
Caleb I'm just gonna throw this out
there so it said okay
you're freaked out
you freaked out with me meeting me
having this conversation in this room at
this moment right but can we just get
past that the whole employer employee
anything it's good to meet you Nathan
it's good to meet you too Kim
[Music]
this building isn't a house
it's a research facility and I want to
talk to you about what I'm researching
[Music]
you want to see something cool
you are dead center of the greatest
scientific event in the history of man
do you have a name Ava
answer me this
how do you feel about it her AI is
beyond doubt no nothing analytical just
how do you feel I feel that she's
amazing dude do you want to be my friend
of course will it be possible why would
it not be
did you know that Nathan Broadway here
to test you
Caleb you're wrong wrong about what
you shouldn't trust anything he says
does Ava actually like you or is she
just pretending to like you
self-awareness manipulation sexuality
are you attracted to me now if that
isn't true AI what is Caleb
or something I want to show you
we talk about the lies you've been
spinning me what lies
test why me
you're up to help me
was a real test you that's strange to
have made something that hates you
what will happen to me if I fail your
test
[Music]
kind of nervous when I take tests take
tests
I've got four skin jobs walking the
streets walking the street they're
either a benefit or a hazard
their benefit it's not my problem not my
problem
[Music]
I'm Rachel
Deckard
have you ever retired a human by mistake
by mistake by mistake
I need the old Blade Runner Blade Runner
this is a bad bad
how can it not know what it is if only
you could see what I have seen when I
have seen what I've seen
more human than human is our motto
what if I go north
disappear but you come after me I don't
even but somebody would
it's too bad
good
time to die
will you help us what seems to be the
problem
I want
life
an experiment nothing more nothing more
more human than humanism
oh yeah
what are you gonna do with it I'm gonna
give it some socially responsibility
can't we just let it go
a game Let's mask up
like the rest of it
[Music]
this world's a treasure
that's been telling us to leave for a
while now
your daughter's generation will be the
last to survive on Earth
you're the best pilot we ever had
get out there and save the world
everybody ready to say goodbye to our
solar system
to our galaxy
here we go
right here
I want to get down fast don't we
actually we want to get there in one
piece
hang on
[Music]
we have a mission our mission does not
work if the people on Earth are dead by
the time we pull it off
[Music]
we got this far farther than any human
in history well not far enough
[Music]
Make It Count
no waves
yes you are yes you are
you might have to decide between senior
children again
and the future of the human race
I'll find a way who we always have
I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
I won't let anything harm you I love her
Megan's not a person to you you don't
get to say that
[Music]
foreign
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
but your full attention
[Music]
what the hell is that
you should probably run
Megan have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
[Music]
Megan baby doll skill don't provoke
you'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ
I thought we were friends
I have a new primary user now me
thank you
did make him do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan
don't be Focus oh we will
have you ever had a dream Neo
that she was so sure was real
what if you were unable to wake from
that dream
the difference between the dream world
and the real world
this can't be you wanted to know what
the Matrix is near
it is the world that has been pulled
over your eyes to Blind you from the
truth what truth
you've been living in a Dream World Neil
as long as the Matrix exists the human
race will never be free
you're mine
you told me the story of the war when
the ground Shook and the sky burned
of the ones that survived
who awoke to a different world
where the powerful prey
but that's not the way it has to be
when I found you your very human brain
was miraculously
it's the loneliest feeling that to know
who you are in time you'll remember
[Music]
a leader is new here thank you
it's a harsh World down here
you better be willing to do what it
takes
I'll leave that run
[Music]
s
she's the last of a Kind she contains
technology that have been lost for 300
years let me show you something
foreign
I feel a connection to it I can't
explain you know more about me than
you're saying Anita some things are
better left forgotten
and I'll find out for myself
she's threatening the natural order of
things I need you to destroy her leader
they will come for you I'll have to face
them head on
way back
tonight is not a game it is a hunt
[Music]
I'm with her
the survivors of the nuclear fire called
The War Judgment Day
[Music]
who sent you you do get down
come with me if you want to live
you just can't go around killing people
why I'm a Terminator
hasta la vista baby
go now
stay down
[Music]
I'll be back
look at me positive for Howard marks I'm
placing you under arrest for the future
murder of Sarah marks and Donald Duman
that was take place today April 22nd at
zero eight hundred hours four minutes
foreign
don't run
everybody runs French
[Music]
foreign
Bell reporting to Central everything
running smoothly over and out rock and
roll God Bless America
good morning Sam do you want me to cut
your hair there
lunar Industries Remains the number one
provider of clean energy worldwide due
to the hard work of people like you
know
three years is a long haul you know I
know you really know
[Music]
it's like we got a live one I'm gonna go
out okay Sam
weeks around working perimeter
I'm outside
you tell me this perhaps you're
imagining things
what's going on where did he come from
why does he look like a man
you've been up here too long man you've
lost your marbles
[Music]
go home I know
we designed them to be trusted with our
homes
a way of life
with our world
but did we design them
to be trusted the rollout of usr's new
generation of robot the ns5 was marred
by the death of designer Alfred Lanning
identify
murder's a new trick for a robot respond
Mr good old days I want good old days
when people were killed by other people
my robots don't kill people that thing
threw somebody out of a window was that
registering with you
trust them if you want to we look to
robots for protection imagine the loss
of all that we've gained because of an
irrational paranoia it's thinking you're
the last sane man on the face of the
Earth make you crazy as if it does maybe
I am baby you can't be looking in the
shadows all the time
you're on the inside help me find out
what is wrong with these robots Dr
Lanning suggested robots might naturally
evolve I was hoping to see you again
detective think of me as your friend why
don't you just hand the world over on a
silver platter maybe we did we're on the
eve of the largest robotic distribution
in history it'll be one robot to every
five humans how many robots have you
ever committed a crime how many robots
in the world none there is no conspiracy
what this is is one mistake oh hell no
foreign
[Music]
I see you remain suspicious of me
detective you know what they say about
old dogs not really
please welcome my partner in science and
in life Dr will Caster the path to build
their super intelligence requires us to
unlock the most fundamental secrets of
the universe
[Music]
imagine and a Sheen with a full range of
human emotion
its analytical power will be greater
than the collective intelligence of
every person in the history of the world
some scientists refer to this as the
singularity Professor I call it
Transcendence
[Applause]
foreign
series of attacks conducted by radical
anti-tech group known as Rift they hit
AI Labs all over the country we lost
Decades of research and development it's
radiation poisoning the bullet must have
been laced with it the effect is
irreversible
Will's body is dying but his mind is a
pattern of electrical signals we can
upload his Consciousness we can save him
not like this
assuming that this works
childhood memory how will you know who
you're dealing with
oh my God I can't feel anything
I'm here
you need to get me online I need more
power you may be intelligent may even be
sent here this is normal
cross the line they don't know the
danger
this is astounding so how do we fight it
you're gone
like any intelligence
it has needs the real world died
and will start to evolve
where's the machine to influence
perhaps the entire world
where are you going
everywhere
deployment of the planet's first robotic
police units
became the focus of the world in 2016.
[Music]
Vincent Moore is a former Soldier
problem with artificial intelligence is
his way to unpredictable
Creator Dion Wilson sees a rich future
what interests me is a machine that can
think and feel
I have a robot that is operated by a
thinking human being we don't want this
it's expensive it's big and it's ugly
the scouts are a huge success stop
worrying about these pet projects
new kind of life for me a new step in
evolution
[Music]
you are chappie
it's like a child it has to learn what's
that Japanese book yeah it's yours Jeff
is good stories
anything you want to do in your life you
can do right poetry have the original
ideas Jimmy wants to be
wow what in the name of the Lord
you don't worry about a big problem for
me a thinking robot could be the end of
mankind
destroy that robot burn it to Ash
something of great danger headed our way
now
I don't want to die I want to live if
you want to survive chapter we must
fight
have begun shutting down
foreign
Consciousness
I'm alive
I am chippy
700 years into the future
mankind will leave our planet
leaving Earth's Cleanup in the hands of
one incredible machine
his name is Wally after all these years
he's developed one little glitch a
personality he's extremely curious
[Applause]
and just a little bit lonely
but all that is about to change
[Music]
my love
oh that's that robot
10 seconds to self-destruct
you are now free to move around the
cabin
you look gorgeous
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
every civilization
was built off the back of a disposable
Workforce
but I can only make so many
happy birthday
[Music]
there is an order to things
that's what we do here
we keep order
[Music]
the world is built on a wall that
separates kind
of tell either side there's no wall
you bought a war
[Music]
foreign
I know
what do you want
I want to ask you some questions
McKay to the Future
[Music]
it's finally Unearthed
bring it to me
you know you're here
[Music]
I always told you you're special
your story isn't over yet
there's still a page left
foreign
[Music]
you have a meeting in five minutes you
want to try getting out of bed get up
here you're too funny
[Music]
human
Theodore I saw in your emails that you'd
gone through a breakup recently you're
kind of nosy am I you'll get used to it
[Music]
what was it like being married there's
something that feels so good about
sharing your life with somebody
how do you share your life with somebody
[Music]
the woman that I've been seeing Samantha
she's an operating system you're dating
in a list what is that like
I feel really closer like when I talk to
her I feel like she's with me
I want to learn everything about
everything I want to discover myself I
want that for you too keep going
I'll keep going
it's kind of like a form of socially
acceptable insanity
you're dating your computer she's not
just a computer you always wanted to
have a wife without the challenges of
actually dealing with anything real I'm
glad that you found someone
[Music]
ever
am I in this because I'm strong enough
for a real relationship is it not a real
relationship
[Music]
fear that you carry around
I wish they could help you let go of it
because I don't think you'd feel so
alone anymore you're beautiful
we're only here briefly and while I'm
here I want to allow myself to awake
[Music]
I'll never loved anyone the hell I love
you
love you me too
me too now we know how
[Music]
it's War
M we're not winning it
if you speak a word of what I'm about to
show you you will be executed for high
treason
beautiful
the greatest encryption device in
history and the Germans use it for all
Communications everyone thinks Enigma is
unbreakable let me try and we'll know
for sure Mr Turing do you know how many
died because of it
I don't three
while we've been having this
conversation
gentlemen meet Mr Turing we used to work
together then I'm afraid these men would
only Slow Me Down popular at school way
short on staff we get more stuff then
you have six minutes to complete the
task it's not even possible no
five minutes and 34 seconds you said to
do it in under six what is it that we're
really doing we're going to break an
unbreakable Nazi code and win the war oh
you know to pull off this irascible
genius routine one actually has to be a
genius
I'm designing a machine that will allow
us to break every message every day
instantly
you're going to need all the help you
can get and they are not going to help
you if they do not like you have you
decrypted a single German message you
will never understand the importance of
what I am creating here our patience has
expired no if you fire Helen well then
you'll have to fire me me too and me you
better bloody work
Helen you do not have to do this alone
what are you doing what's going on Navy
thinks that one of us is a Soviet spy
you've got more secrets than the best of
them what if I don't fancy her in that
way can't tell anyone no it's illegal
I'm just a mathematician sometimes it is
the people who no one imagines anything
else
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I can see the judge's eyes as he handed
you the prize I bet you made the cutest
bomb
oh you must have been a beautiful baby
baby look at you now
[Music]
hello Morgan
how are you feeling
I'm feeling
not quite myself
[Music]
where's Morgan
oh you must have been a beautiful baby
[Applause]
you're sick I'm feeling much better
baby look at you now
[Music]